gegen gibt geht zur neige positive
entwicklung bei der
kindersterblichkeitsrate und neuigkeiten
im fall ballack
das sind nur drei der fünf themen heute
in den klicks und topnews in wenigen
sekunden eine wunde verschließen das
soll schon bald möglich sein wer sich
schon einmal beim gemüse schneiden
geschnitten hat der kennt diese
hektische suche nach einem passenden
pflaster das blut tropft den finger
entlang und dann soll man sich auch noch
ein pflaster zurechtschneiden geschweige
denn aufkleben rolando lina ist ein 22
jahre alter mann der im alter von 17
jahren eine geniale idee hatte die idee
ein gel das in wenigen sekunden bunten
verschließt jetzt wurde seine idee von
offizieller seite aus genehmigt
allerdings nur in den usa und nur am
tiermedizinischen bereich das wti geht
besteht aus algen die körpereigenen
reparatur fasern die fibeln fasern
werden von den alten gestützt somit
dauert das ganze nur wenige sekunden
wtg darf aktuell wie gesagt nur in der
medizin und in den usa verwendet werden
aber 2016 könnte es erstmals am
menschlichen körper getestet werden für
den jungen forscher joel angelina könnte
das der durchbruch sein
im klicks um fanfiction video auf
unserer facebook-seite berichteten wir
bereits über folgendes thema experten
gelang es krebszellen zu stoppen
dem statistischen bundesamt zufolge
sterben jährlich circa 200 24.000
menschen an krebs krebs ist somit hinter
dem herz und kreislauf erkrankungen die
zweithäufigste todesursache
hier in deutschland eine krebserkrankung
zu bekämpfen ist alles andere als leicht
experten der meinung kliniken freude
haben im fachmagazin nature cell biology
eine neue relativ unkomplizierte methode
zur krebsbekämpfung vorgestellt es ist
ihnen gelungen den scheinbar
unaufhaltsame wachstum der krebszellen
zu verlangsamen
gesunde zellen stoffen ihre zellteilung
sobald sie kein platz mehr haben oder
sich ausreichend oft genug geteilt haben
krebszellen dagegen teilen sich einfach
weiter und weiter
diese endlose schleife der zellteilung
konnten die forscher der mayo klinik mit
hilfe einer mikro rna entschleunigen das
protein plh a72 für den stopp
signal bei gesunden zellen
verantwortlich krebszellen bekommen
dieses signal arbeit nicht mit der mikro
rna konnten die forscher die krebszellen
ein solches signal geben so simpel das
alles klingt so simpel ist es aber
leider nicht
zitat es wird noch lange dauern bis wir
wissen ob diese untersuchungsergebnisse
mit labor zellen tatsächlich auch
krebspatienten helfen können so henry
scowcroft vom britischen
krebsforschungszentrum neuigkeiten im
fall müller im juli berichteten wir von
der rückkehr des ebola erreger nach
liberia
im august von dem impfstoff vsv auf der
100 prozentigen schutz von ebola schon
nach einer woche möglich machen soll
und jetzt gibt es eine neue meldung
liberia gilt der
weltgesundheitsorganisation bhu zur
folge wieder als ebola frei seit 2003
zehn kämpfen tausende menschen gegen den
ebola erreger im mai 2015 wurde die wäre
das erste mal nach dem ebola ausbruch im
jahr 2013 das ebola frei bezeichnet
42 tage später gab es aber einen
dramatischen fall ein 17 jähriger starb
an den folgen der infektion
der leblose körper des jungen mannes sei
positiv auf den erreger getestet worden
am 24 juni nicht weit entfernt von
internationalen und die bärischen
flughafen niederrhein verstarb der
jugendliche jetzt wo die bären wieder
den status ebola frei bekommen hat
bleibt das den menschen in liberia zu
wünschen dass nicht wieder ein
dramatischer fall den status zunichte
macht eben den erfreulichen neuigkeiten
aus liberia gibt es eine weitere
positive entwicklung zu vermelden
in einem aktuellen bericht der unicef
der whu der weltbank und der un
abteilung für wirtschaftliche und
soziale angelegenheiten wird von der
niedrigsten kindersterblichkeitsrate
seit 1990 gesprochen bis zum ende diesen
jahres würden fast sechs millionen
kinder keine fünf jahre ihres lebens auf
dieser welt verbringen kann wenn man von
sechs millionen froh dass finden
kindesalter spricht klingt das nach
einer grausamen großen zahl das ist auch
eine grausam große zahl im jahr 1990
waren das allerdings 12,7 millionen
kinder
die positive entwicklung nimmt zum glück
noch kein ende zitat wir wissen wie die
sterblichkeit unter neugeborenen weiter
verringert werden kann so die
stellvertretende direktorin der whu klar
airbus 3
diese aussage klingt vielversprechend da
45 prozent der sechs millionen kinder im
ersten lebensmonat versterben würden
das gegengift geht aus welches gegengift
fragt ihr euch jetzt wahrscheinlich das
ist von dem gegengift fabrik die rede
die organisation ärzte ohne grenzen
teilte mit dass im juni 2016 die letzten
fabrik medikamente abgelaufen sein
zudem wird seit 2014 kein neues fabrik
fabriziert wird also längere zeit kein
derartiges medikament geben
bis ein vergleichbares medikament zum
einsatz kommen wird kann es den ersten
über grenzen nach gute zwei jahre dauern
eifrig wird beispielsweise bei mama
wissen oder bei vielen weiteren anderen
giftschlangen bisschen verwendet um den
gebissenen das leben zu retten
der weltgesundheitsorganisation who
zufolge sterben jedes jahr in etwa
100000 menschen an schlangengift und
circa fünf millionen menschen werden von
schlangen gebissen
wenn man sich diese zahlen vor augen
hält kann man nur hoffen dass es keine
zwei jahre dauert bis ein neues
medikament entwickelt wird könnt ihr
euch vorstellen wie es passieren kann
dass man ein scheinbar essentiell das
gegengift einfach so nicht mehr
herstellt tragt es uns in die kommentare
unter dieses video ich bin auf eure
meinung gespannt
moment moment moment dass videos noch
nicht zu ende ich sitz hier eben
eigentlich einfach bulli von volkswagen
financial services auf dem kanal bin ich
nämlich jetzt auch zu sehen
die kollegen haben mich gefragt ob ich
nicht lust hätte finanzthemen auch so
einfach zu erklären wie auf klicks und
ich habe mich gerne bereit erklärt diese
herausforderung anzunehmen allerdings
werde ich gott sei dank unterstützt von
richtigen finanzexperten von volkswagen
financial services die themen erklären
zum beispiel wie spar ich auf eine
weltreise wie bezahlen mit dem
smartphone wie funktioniert das mit der
immobilienfinanzierung und so weiter und
so fort wenn euch das interessiert
schaut unbedingt auf dem kanal von
volkswagen financial services vorbei
abonniert ihn und ich freue mich auf
euch dort